Hello Freak bitches 200 years ago.
The day where they're all like,
what the fuck are we doing?
I'm not wearing the wig,
bro.
I'm not wearing the fucking wig.
Like leg day.
I should bring it back.
Fuck it.
My hair fell out.
I'm gone.
Pattern.
We'll with you at the comedy store.
You,
you and me,
fanny pack,
400 wigs.
Fuck yeah.
Fanny packs right here.
Dude.
Right there on that.
That's right.
I,
I wear mine all the time and my son gave
me shit about it and then guess what?
Six months later he's like,
Dad,
he's still got that fanny pack.
Oh,
he wants what?
He's wearing those I'll get 'em one.
Yeah,
I've got some my higher primate ones,
right?
The right ones.
I'll give you one of those,
didn't I?
Yeah.
I wear it all the time.
That's what I'm saying.
All all praise be the dice clay.
He started it.
Yeah.
Well I always wore fanny packs.
I've been wearing fanny packs forever,
but they were crappy and
then dice clay came in.
I went,
what is this exceptional piece of
hardware you have around your waist?
It was like,
oh,
you'll like this.
Oh yes,
it's from roots.
Roots.
Fanny pack is fucking beautiful.
The way it clips together,
it's like it's perfect size.
Organize Shit in my pockets.
Tries [inaudible] new phone is,
I take everything out of my
pockets wherever I go and
I lose shit shorts at all.
There's nothing in my pockets.
My little man bags.
That's it.
I wore a fanny pack this morning.
I got a sports one cause I ran.
Ooh.
Those are good.
And I put it around my waist.
The little sports ones.
Oh yeah.
Oh by the way,
shit my pants while running this morning.
Did you?
Not Hard.
Just a,
it was a shark.
I was coming up a hill.
I was,
I was in mile for it.
Had nothing left and I,
and I thought I had to fart and
just Bam shard and my underwear.
I did that the other day in my house.
Yeah,
just a little squirt.
And Jesus Christ feels
like such a failure,
but it had some good farts before that.
That's a problem.
Yeah.
I got motivated because I had,
so you were on a roll rumblers
watch Jesus and it was just me.
I wish I didn't have to
cover from no worries.
I was pausing and leaning into
them and then it just a little,
ah,
fuck ah,
catch the shower.
That's a shower.
But it was interesting because
as soon as I got on the bowl,
all of a sudden I had explosive diarrhea.
I'm like,
where was this?
Like I'd had no idea that's up.
Diarrhea was looming.
Meanwhile,
holiday eating,
that's holiday eating probably.
Yeah.
Well,
creams and Shit Wad also,
I go off the Diet and I started eating
like Pumpkin Pie and ice cream and shit
and all the cream.
Yeah,
with a lot of bread.
I had a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich last night,
but as the ultimate failure,
because your job as a human is to
provide for your family and not shit your
pants.
You think about it all the time.
Every time you fart,
you,
there's a little moment
where you weigh in on it,
you feel it out,
feel your intestines,
you feel your anus,
you make a judgment
call and you let it rip.
What's interesting,
if you think about how in you are to
the sensations you get from your inner
colon,
because there's times you know like,
oh no,
I'm about to shit my pants.
There's like a,
there's a certain alarm that
goes off like when you're like,
oh no,
no,
we're coaching a little too hard here.
Okay,
we've got a problem here boys.
We got a runner,
we got a runner,
we got her runner.
Barely it in Kiki.
Close the Yay
clamping down.
And it's the same exact
feeling that you get is when
you're trying to hold common.
You know that Domo Shit.
Yeah,
like Superbad clamping
everything in like that.
I've,
I'll always say one day
I'm gonna try Tantra.
I'm going to learn how to like completely
like guys say that you can have like
an internal orgasm for your,
your contractions so long that you come,
but no,
come,
comes out and your body reabsorbs it.
And it makes you look Super Sayan power.
Yeah,
I've choke one back.
Wow.
Just got to grab the base right
before impact and squeeze really hard.
It's got to be long
enough where it begins,
but not so long that it comes out.
And I've pushed it back in again.
But what if you cause an injury?
Yeah,
that's the problem.
What if you get crazy and
you just really grab it?
It's why I've only done
it a couple of times.
And you broke your own deck
because you grabbed it too hard.
God Damn,
life would not be worth living.
Can you imagine that?
Not Having your Dick come anymore for
the rest of your life and knowing that
what percentage of your life revolves
around getting rid of come once a day.
Okay,
but once a day.
So if it's once a day,
if it's even 45 minutes of your time,
the other 23 hours and
15 minutes are bullshit.
You thinking like,
this is what I can't lose.
I can't lose the
balancing myself to a lot of guys,
like if you had to choose between being
blind or having your Dick break where
you,
dick can never get it up again.
Oh,
no question.
What would you say?
Give me the fucking stick and the dog.
Give
me the Stevie wonder glasses.
Very superstitious
and he's getting laid after the show.
[inaudible].